les congressistes ont adopté le principe
de la création officielle du nouveau
parti socialiste
4 mai 1969 alfortville
c'est la naissance du parti socialiste
un nouveau nom pour remplacer la s et
filles au la section française de
l'internationale ouvrière
l'objectif rallier les divers courants
socialistes à la veille de la
présidentielle anticipée de 1969 au
terme de débats houleux
gaston defferre le président du groupe
des députés socialistes est alors
désigné candidat du nouveau ps pour
l'élection
vous ne craignez pas qu'il y ait une
certaine situation assez difficile à
gauche je ne pense pas je pense que
après cette journée qu'ils étaient avec
du monde jaune et bleu difficile des
choses entre comptait s'éclaircir et que
peu situation s'améliorera je pense que
d'ici la fin de la campagne électorale
la situation pour le candidat de gauche
aura une bonne situation l'entousiasme
de gaston defferre et la nouvelle unité
socialiste ne suffiront pas à convaincre
l'électorat français de faire ne
recueille que 5% des voix le pire score
de toute l'histoire du parti socialiste
une situation décrypté par ce sociologue
au moment où l'on voulait créer un
nouveau parti socialiste
l'échéance présidentielle l'a mené à
l'éclatement
pour la première fois le ps est exclu du
second tour de l'élection présidentielle
l'histoire se répètera 48 ans plus tard
en 2017
en ce début de cinquième république
certains ne croyaient déjà plus au parti
socialiste
s'il a pas l'importance qu'il a 7 pts du
fait de ses hésitations et de ses prises
de position pas toujours très nettes
qu'il est dépassé et se prêtent un parti
de gauche et un monde
de plus une reconquête électorale sans
pause alors pour le ps en 1971 au
congrès d'epinay les socialistes
s'unissent deux niveaux cette fois
françois mitterrand rejoint le ps et
devient même son premier secrétaire
il prône alors une entente avec le
puissant parti communiste pour la future
conquête du pouvoir
celui qui dit qu'on s'en va à la rupture
avec l'ordre établi
oliv69 soir secondaire avec la société
capitaliste
celui là je le dis il ne peut pas être
adhérent du parti
dix ans plus tard l'union des gauches et
l'alliance stratégique avec les
communistes porteront ses fruits en 1981
françois mitterrand devient le premier
président socialiste de la vème
république
[Musique]